in a world divided by politics and
separated into camp Edward in camp Jacob
here are 15 things we can all agree on
it is impossible to look cool taking a
picture with an iPad even if you're
wearing all pink and even if you're
Spike Lee Nutella is the nectar of the
Gods and it should be eaten never worn
this is humiliating for cheerleaders for
dogs for Obama there are a few things
more frightening than a picture of a
basset hound running except for this
slow-motion video of a basset hound
playing tug-of-war with what appears to
be a small pink pig frightening using
permanent marker on someone's face is an
unacceptable party prank whereas the
face tattoo is dainty subtle and
inviting and I'm lying and no one
absolutely no one looks better making
the duck face we can all agree that no
child should be put on a leash it's
embarrassing
for Obama and we can all agree that this
child is the luckiest child in the world
if you're going to eat snacks on a bus
you need to really commit to it that's
right mayonnaise out of a jar let's all
agree the Ducks should keep their masks
on because they're scary as [ __ ] when
they don't frightening some people
should probably not be on Facebook and
yes dear we're in Paris we're always in
Paris and finally let's agree that the
baby echidna is highly underrated now
let's all just get along
[Music]
Wow